the maternal family of Olivia welcomed
the findings of the coroner's inquest
into her tragic and unnecessary death
the last four years have been the
hardest and most difficult Journey we
could have embarked on
to lose our wonderful vivacious and
captivating girl in circumstances which
we now know
were avoidable
we have been fighting for the truth of
what really happened since she passed
and the story we were presented with by
the ministry of defense was very
different to the conclusion that has now
been reached by the coroner
well let's cross live to reading and our
correspondent Alice Porter and Alice
there we heard mention of that
conclusion from the inquest tell us what
that conclusion was
well we heard in court today that Olivia
perks very much started her training at
Sandhurst very bubbly incredibly
hard-working but it was very apparent
quite early on that her mental health
took a serious toll and quite early on
she made a suicide attempt early on into
her training now although the coroner
applauded the attempts by the primary
care team and how they dealt with it at
the time the coroner Alison McCormick
also said the situation brought to life
failings within the welfare system at
Sandhurst and crucially said that that
there was only one welfare officer for
more than two and a half thousand people
and that welfare officer had no prior
training she said Liv's welfare was not
managed in accordance with army policy
for vulnerable people I think that was
one of the main ethnic messages which
came through in the inquest today was
that there were safeguarding policies in
place but Alison McCormick criticized
the Army for not doing enough to take
the these on and actually put them into
practice when it came with to Olivia and
it's very much came to to her head
really in the year of her death in 2019
and it was in that February and what was
one of the most shocking aspects I think
really that came through with this
inquest was that despite relationships
between Cadets those who are training
and members of Staff being banned she
did Olivia perks did have a relationship
with a member of staff and in the weeks
week leading up to her death she spent
the night with one of the color
sergeants and it was rumors that were
then circulating she was incredibly
embarrassed about the situation and the
coroner criticized the Army for not
making a referral to the medical team
when she started self-harming she was
banging in her head and sadly only a few
days later she took her own life now the
Army have said how sorry they are for
what has happened and they did an
internal inquiry last year into what
happened they made 61 recommendations
and they were heard in court previously
and the coroner said she very much hoped
that Olivia's Legacy will that be very
much that those recommendations that the
Army found will be put into practice